yeah they're really like [ __ ] fluffy
chocolate not fluffy but like they're
really like
bubbly chocolate yeah yeah i gotta be
good yeah
i don't know like i really really
[ __ ] like aero right but then i just
realized
chocolate bar would you like some
chocolate air
you know sometimes when you buy the
expensive chocolate like
lint or lindora the [ __ ] they are blind
whatever there is i don't know swiss
chocolate yeah you know sometimes you
eat one and you're like that's good it's
good but do i really want like 10.
like it's not like a chocolate you eat
ten of yeah i've no that's what i've
noticed about expensive chocolate
it's like you eat one and you feel like
you've just ate ten chocolate bars in
this one
yeah yeah and then you're like great i
paid 50 bucks for these 10 chocolates
like this was it time to give them away
i guess
what i do now i don't really want to eat
these anymore that's why i like shitty
chocolate it's
like you could eat so much it's like
it's so good like you never get bored of
it like dairy milk
i never get bored of that i i just can't
even like really eat a lot of chocolate
anymore
no no neither yeah but big macs yeah
hell yeah okay
i'll do it i can smash a big mac bag
every day mcflurry [ __ ] yeah yeah i
don't know i i ice cream is
uh i think my love is grown for ice
cream really older
but my love for chocolate has gone down
i don't know why i think
i love the chocolate it's pretty mvp
though yeah i think my luffa chocolate
and ice cream's just kind of gone down
recently i don't know
my love for sweet things has definitely
gone down yeah you're already sweet
enough joey it's oh
i definitely do like my savory and
saltier stuff better yeah cause for me
like i think you know a lot of people
say you have a second stomach for
dessert i don't have a second stomach
that's [ __ ] i'm just like i'm just
like if if i have if i have
space in my stomach for more food then
i'm going to eat more food yeah right
right exactly
right i mean if there is a tour of
available i will always make room for a
tiramisu
okay to be fair if a tiramisu comes out
i'm smashing that [ __ ]
that has to be my favorite cake what's
your favorite cake
a i don't know this is like asking an
alien maybe your favorite celebrity
i guess uh the human on the tv is my
favorite i guess if not like the default
chocolate cake then probably red velvet
i [ __ ] love red velvet red velvet is
good red velvet is probably like the
only other cake that i
like like to eat other than chocolate
red velvet is very good yeah
i can't eat a chocolate cake anymore
it's it's just way too heavy now
yeah it depends like i never
and you know you you know when you're
[ __ ] you know when you're hungry and
you feel like you can
you can eat everything right yeah and so
when i get this chocolate craving i buy
like [ __ ]
i i [ __ ] like buy 10 different types
of chocolate bars chocolate ice cream
chocolate cake i'm just like
i'm [ __ ] craving this i'm hungry
enough to eat everything i have one bite
of the chocolate cake and i'm just like
okay i'm done now
[ __ ] i've made a massive mistake because
i just have
a table table full of just chocolate in
front of me that i know i don't want to
eat anymore
god but uh yeah i just i don't really
i'm not really i'm not a dessert guy
are you a dessert guy i mean i i prefer
the main but sometimes
some places have like really good
desserts and it makes you feel like okay
hold up
could you go have you ever been that's
got a point have you ever been to like
uh cake buffets
is that way wrong that's a thing what is
that oh okay
where is this in japan they're [ __ ]
everywhere what where yeah there's one
there's one really good one i went to in
harajuku where it's like
it's literally like a sushi train of
cakes of like tiny little cakes
how much how many can you have before
you start becoming sick i had like
four and then i was done but like some
of my female friends can have like you
know 10
15 of these guys
sweet [ __ ] yeah i like cupcakes cupcakes
are nice something about a muffin or a
cupcake i think i've had a cupcake in
like
five years it's just muffin i just like
muffins pretty easy
muffins pretty good science what is it
about muffins that are very british
something i think it's very american i'd
say yeah i think it's more american
when i think muffin i think british i
don't know why the english muffin
you're thinking ah could be yeah it
could be because i feel like definitely
with
dessert dessert culture is way stronger
in asia than i feel when i was like
living in england
um because i didn't like until i moved
to thailand i went to thailand i didn't
know the concept of just like a dessert
bar
where it's just like a restaurant that
just specifically
just serves desserts yeah that's just
not a thing anymore there's some
like what oh was it like casper or
whatever it's called what the [ __ ] is
this it's a big train i saw it
everywhere
it was like a dessert thing but it was
like really tacky i didn't really like
the look of it yeah like the the only
kind of dessert oriented places that i
find in england now are just
like they they are marketed as like
asian like dessert places right
and and that only started cropping up
more recent in more recent times i'm
also not a fan of like
how [ __ ] bright and loud dessert
places are
i feel like i'm you know what i mean
almost exclusively white as [ __ ] they're
always like really pastel colors or
bright colors and i just feel like [ __ ]
i mean you get blinded when you walk
into one i'm like
i
[Laughter]
i'm too british for this i'm too sad i
can't i can't be in here
i say the fact that like all of them all
of the walls are just
white as [ __ ] and they blast the light
on and i'm like oh god it's too easy
it's 2pm why are the lights on in here
when you use light mode
just depends on the place yeah i mean
you get different types of uh lighting
and
of walls whatever the [ __ ] i don't know
yeah do you ever are you one of those
people who like
care about the mood of a restaurant like
yeah
the lighting yeah yeah yeah definitely
helps with uh
get a feel for what the owner wanted
right yeah i didn't start to care about
it until
kind of kind of like i say i would say
like my mid-20s i mean yeah they got
like they got to like build the
atmosphere before you even sit down
yeah like they gotta like get you like
understanding the vibe what
the food yeah because before when i was
like a [ __ ] uni student or something
it's not not just restaurants i didn't
care about the bar vibe you know what i
mean
like to me if it's does it serve food is
it cheap can i eat it yeah true that's
all i cared about
right but like as i grown as i like grew
older i'm just like
damn like sure like the vibe from the
place can really affect if i'm enjoying
my meal or drink
as much as usual and i didn't i don't
know i don't know if just like something
switched into my brain or something
but there's a part of me that's like i
feel the if a restaurant has like
really nice mood or like a mood that is
fitting and is comforting yeah then it
almost
sometimes blinds you to the fact that
the food might not be as good as you
think it is
i know i mean there's plenty of times
where it sets up like high expectations
yeah yeah the food comes out and it's
interesting it's so disappointing
yeah right because it's it's especially
in japan
right because i feel like especially in
japan every place has a unique vibe yeah
every restaurant you go to looks amazing
it has like a unique selling point
um but that isn't always that this
isn't always uh that doesn't always
equate to good food yeah well it doesn't
always equate to amazing
weirdly enough it's like kind of the
opposite in japan where like the
shittier the place looks
usually the better the food is
especially when it comes to like ramen
family-owned restaurants and stuff like
that yeah if the sign is falling apart
in the ramen place it's pretty pretty
good
because i wouldn't give a [ __ ] about how
it looks